hi there reject nation of Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey we just got out of Quentin
Tarantino's Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood the night film Tarantino is
the greatest filmmaker of all time if he
can do nothing wrong every film is the
best every yeah really quick before we
go into that my brother did an interview
with Ryan George over at screenrant's
pitch meeting so I'm hoping does his own
pitch meeting for Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood my brother was like hey do you
mind mentioning this I was like no you
dick that was the one interview in my
whole life I've ever wanted it
conducting you did it I listened to the
whole thing it is a great interview so
putting all jealousy aside please go
check it out cuz it really is it is a
wonderful interview news with someone I
would love to interview myself one day
back to the movie you know even though
it's Saturday I heard something recently
of Tarantino saying he's mad at people
doing spoiler reviews or like so early
and whatnot there are things you can't
definitely spoil but we're not gonna go
into that today I'm here to tell you
that Tarantino buy your ticket buy more
as much as people have talked a lot
about especially when this movie was
first announced so Darren Tina's doing a
Manson movie it's definitely more of
what you saw in the trailers it's
primarily a film that focuses on the
individual lives in the relationship
between DiCaprio and Brad Pitt's
character rick dalton and cliff booth
rick dalton being an actor who is on the
verge of being a husband and cliff booth
is his you know a best friend slash
stunt double slash life caretaker man
the best way I could describe this movie
the slice of life genre but with the
Tarantino style to slice of life this is
how Tarantino would do a slice of life
out his new wave is Tarrington yet
because you're capturing individual
lives there the relationship which are
also capturing a very specific time
period in Los Angeles 1969 I thought he
brought all that to life really well
well not always subtle there's also a
pretty good amount of
subtlety that's done throughout you know
in terms of all of this films I think it
has the least obtrusive or or you could
say obnoxious visual style I don't I
rarely find his visual style obnoxious
but I know some people do and yet it is
the least high on like crazy cut-ins yes
you Brian house aesthetics and stuff
well it's deliberately pasted it really
takes its time I've heard some people
describe this as like a hangout movie
with these characters and when I heard
that I'm like oh kind of like Jackie
Brown because that's how Tarantino said
Jackie Brown was his hangout yeah no
it's not like that specific direction
it's going it has a lot more tension in
it it's more plot heavy than this film
because there is a point in this movie
and I've heard other people say you
start asking yourself like where's this
movie going like what exactly is the
narrative to this film are we just
watching people's lives unfold
sometimes with Tarantino he does get a
pass on certain things and other
directors wouldn't because of the fact
that he is Tarantino I just got to admit
that right up front because whenever I
had that thought with this film I was
like well let me just wait till the end
because it's Tarantino and I trust what
he's gonna do that's the way it works of
the guy you know like I just I feel like
that'll happen and also I think what why
I never really felt that even though I
think the length of this film is felt
and while I think there are some things
that were a little too self-indulgent
that it could have been trimmed out of
this movie ultimately I thought using
the whole thing about how we are going
to get to that time in life where the
Sharon Tate murder occurred that's
what's been pitched as that was a cool
sort of structure to check in on of
leading into that because you know that
it's building to that moment so I
thought that was clever cuz while that's
not the primary focus of the film is
Sharon Tate because we check in with the
cult in jackets that is a bat she hears
you in a place in time it still has a
direction that you know it's headed
towards and you know we're gonna get to
that moment we don't know when you're
waiting for that I know it's coming yeah
somehow it helps keep a direction of
where the narrative is actually going
yeah it is like a geographical
centerpiece yes I gotta say Brad Pitt is
my favorite character in this whole
movie I think DiCaprio is awesome
ever seen him play a character like this
with so much insecurity I don't want to
go into too much detail other than that
he is wonderful Leonardo DiCaprio in the
film and I love a lot of the little tics
and mannerisms that he's added into
every specific kind of conversation he
was having that's all I'll say and I
might notice it like there are certain
people who talks to where he behaves a
little differently but that's because of
the social circumstance he's in now
there's a lot I mean there's a lot of
really great really lived in really
personality heavy acting throughout this
movie but Brad Pitt he's just he's the
guy you just love I love every time he's
on screen I'm having such a good like
rock Sampson he's like he's the guy you
want to be and funny enough I think
their relationship is interesting
because Brad Pitt is the guy DiCaprio
plays all the time and arguably wants to
be he's like the real version yeah of
who DiCaprio is always dressing up as
all the time and it's interesting the
way the movie kind of at least examines
their roles in both Hollywood and life
as men in that you know window you make
a stunt double character who's really
did the actual badass in this version of
real life and you know arguably in in a
version of life it makes sense yeah you
know and as he's doing literally all the
dirty work and their chemistry together
is wonderful yeah like they when they're
on-screen together the movie is truly at
its best in terms of performance it's
really comfortable together yeah you
know it's so cool to be like oh man I've
been such a fan of both of their works
for so many years this was a little kid
and you know also the fact that like I
you was an inglorious that he was in
Django now they're here yeah I thought
Margot Robbie did a really good job I'll
admit I didn't fully grasp why she was
portrayed the way she was portrayed I've
heard a few reasons that people
theorized to each Tarantino rejects her
hypothesis that was that we don't hear
her actually speaking very much well I
just reject your hypotheses I am
he can explain it oh that I've heard
some people say that it's like capturing
the innocence of like oh that we lost
with her some people have said that yeah
well he has to kind of play it safe you
know real-life characters we got to play
it safe yeah this is this is a script I
would be very fascinated to hear about
the conception of either way even though
I didn't fully grasp it I'm sure maybe
on a second viewing and I it's Tarantino
films I'm gonna watch it again I might
get her portrayal a little bit more but
coming off of this from 20 minutes ago I
do think that margot robbie does do a
really good job and does bring an energy
one of the quieter performances in this
film to life yeah she brought up I guess
with the film's handling of her
character I thought that she brought
something welcome to the Tarantino
palette that whole side of the story
because this is arguably at least to me
one of his least chatty movies yeah and
so many of the Sharon Tate sequences
especially are visually driven and aura
driven I think that does appear
throughout this movie but especially
with her and as Tarantino goes as a
director I do appreciate him kind of at
least branching out in that respect I
feel like this is his most to date
contemplative arguably most sort of
sympathetic movie yeah it's a different
kind of life when I say safe
self-indulgent literally the only thing
that I found a little too like a little
too much at times the weird part is I
also really loved a lot of it is with
Rick Dalton he's an actor and so you see
a lot of the shows and work he's done
yeah you know and you know it's not a
lot of movies with chalk that up to
montages ya know you get so much and you
get a really live in these shows there
are times where it becomes like I get it
but then there's also times where I'm
like that's [ __ ] really
it really is there's scenes where he's
you know being the actor there's moments
where you're gonna see him shooting
something and I thought it was cool how
they captured a world where most
directors will show you a lot of oh
here's the camera crew there's the crew
and the lights he puts you into the
scene as if you're watch if you're just
an audience member watching the scene
and I thought that was really unique and
did
to the point where when Rick Dalton is
acting as a different character he's
doing a great job as a character so I
thought that was really exactly I
thought that was really [ __ ] smart
man I think some of the clip stuff I'm
like okay yeah all right there's also
times I really love that and especially
those specific sequences I'm talking
about where you really get a watch
DiCaprio play Rick Dalton who's playing
a character like that's great through
that character I mean this is also the
first time I've gotten I don't know if
this is true at all but it's the first
time I've gotten a sense that maybe
Tarantino is putting a bit of his own
emotion and his own place in the world
in his business etcetera into a
character and like I said that could be
totally wrong but you know film is
changing he's older in his life this is
about a guy who's going through a
changing landscapes 1969 were at 2019
the decades about to roll over again it
was nice to me to glean that dimension
from a Tarantino movie because up until
this point I'm sure you can but no other
Tarantino movie has made me think about
the inner life of him it's called Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood and it's more
than just a tribute to you know this the
the Western titles yeah we all love me
like Once Upon a Time in America or Once
Upon a Time in the West or Once Upon a
Time in Mexico yeah where he gave that
suggestion it does have a hint of a
fairy tale tone to it just a bit and
that's why I think it's important to
wait till like the end of the movie to
really get the whole package before
judging it oh and the question is is
whether or not the journey to there is
that are you gonna find that really well
worth it in the end I don't know if
you're not a Tarantino fan I'm not sure
how you're gonna feel about this
honestly I don't know if you're gonna
like it as much and yeah if you have no
love for old Hollywood or you know
exploring that time period because
there's a lot of it's kind of very in
the know I don't know how you're gonna
respond to it but the fact is like we're
doing this review we're both Tarantino
figure up in LA we both love Hollywood
we're the perfect target market for this
film
that's just a blunt fact about it I
don't know how someone in Missouri's
gonna respond every but you know someone
like us we're really gonna respond quite
positively to this I think there is a
bunch of other performances in here a
lot of urges like cool cameo does a good
job in the movie I've heard some people
be a little bit critical of the way
Bruce Lee's portrayed in this movie Oh
Michael oh yeah I love that scene yeah
I'm gonna talk I have friends who have
is it a little cartoony sure there's
points where you're like but Bruce Lee
or do you know yeah but I think because
of the tone that it's struck and that
and that it's so self-aware in that
moment when the point is you're seeing
of a moment that only the people on a
set would see yeah that you know is
completely divorced from our image of
Bruce Lee but I loved that scene it's a
great scene I do think that yeah there's
it's not as tense as other Tarantino
films it's a little bit more of a like
of a laid-back ride so I wasn't always
emotionally gripped by it but I was
always pulled in and I was always
interested in what was going on I do
think the most intense moments do come
from whenever we are checking in with
Sharon Tate Manson related stuff
naturally what I because that's when the
movie really plays on your knowledge of
history and then just the proximity of
the characters is actually very
interesting kind of tension they draw
throughout this movie that kind of
matches the city it takes place
definitely you know it's this slightly
foreboding sort of bubbling undercurrent
I also think too that you know this
isn't like the movie us were like we got
a real watch this and I sucked
everything but I think more than any of
Tarantino's other films this is also a
movie where I think there are stuff that
is open to interpretation and there are
things that are open to hypothesizing
yeah
like coming up with why did he do it
this way why was it done this way most
Tarantino films are they're pretty
direct well they're a while they're
always nuanced while very twisty and
turny oh wow there's a lot of depth and
all those things you could get a lot of
different interpretations upon a repeat
value I think there are certain
executions done here that do
intentionally make you go you should
really go back a second time and revisit
that to see how I feel about it and this
is definitely the most I've ended
Tarantino movie thinking about okay I
want to go back and maybe catch a couple
of these themes and maybe figure out why
this moment played the way this one
right did instead of yeah going back in
Mealing oh man I gotta catch all the
details and see it's gonna take me a
little while to figure out where I
qualitatively stand on this movie in
terms of like a letter grade or where a
thumb goes but I do think that this
movie gives a lot to dissect and
appreciate if you want to I think
there's a lot of good craft on display
say we're confident and say what you
will about the way the story handles
itself and I feel like that's where you
can argue the most but I do think this
film gives us something interesting to
think about as some themes that are
worth touching on and also sees
Tarantino traveling into slightly
uncharted territory for his Sensibility
definitely it's it's not the save the
cat structure every that every Hollywood
movie is where it's like I wasn't seen
advancing the plot because it's not
about that that's why I wanted to open
this with that slice comment this is
arguably his least plot Orion know it
seems like he knows that [ __ ] out of
each one even the most minor characters
it seems like he really knows the entire
background in each one of these and you
just get a chance to explore some cool
Tarantino fleshed out characters I give
it a pretty high recommendation it's
definitely worth checking out and
joining the debatable yeah it's one of
those did you guys see one spent time in
Hollywood what do you think about it
don't be a dick and spoil it for people
that only opportunities cool there are
some people who get like credits at in
the movie at the beginning where I'm
like oh they must play like really big
characters all the time like I never
mind
couple of names on the poster who I'm
like you're in one see no one sees you
guys can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell catch you
guys